hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast planet scale analysis
with millions of genomes presented by
dr. Alexander wait is ironic I'm dr.
Michael che of Harvard Medical School
where I am the director of human
subjects research for the Personal
Genome Project and I'll be your
moderator for today's event this
educational web seminar is presented by
lab roots you can learn more about lab
roots by visiting lab roots calm before
we begin I'd like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you like
at any time during the presentation just
click on the green Q&A button located in
the lower left of the presentation
window and type your question into the
box that appears on the screen well
answer as many questions as we have time
for at the end of the presentation also
please notice that you'll be viewing the
presentation in a slide window to
enlarge the window just click on the
screen icon located on the lower right
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the
support button at the top right of the
presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem also note this is an
educational webinar and offers free
continuing education credits pace race
cme or CEU if you'd like to obtain
credit after the webinar is over you may
click on the c/e button located on the
bottom left corner of your screen that
will lead you through the process and
now it's my pleasure to introduce dr.
alexander weight in cirrhotic who I've
known since grad school and who I am I
worked with for many years now doctors
erotic is co-founder and chief scientist
secure verse a venture back company
focused on building a free and open
source platform for storing analyzing
and sharing biomedical data Alexander or
as I've always known him sasha works on
open technologies that are part of the
revolution that reduced the human DNA
sequencing costs by a million fold since
the completion of the Human Genome
Project he's been a leader and strong
advocate for strong rope and software
and genomic information throughout his
professional career his contributions
have led to highly cited publications
science nature The Lancet and other
leading scientific journals recently he
presented his work at the White House
open science Champions of Change event
currently Sasha's research includes the
development of clinical quality
applications for processing massive data
sets spending millions of individuals
across many collaborating organizations
together these data sets are expected to
reach exabytes in size prior to
co-founding Kurvers sasha was a
co-founder and director of informatics
at the Harvard Personal Genome Project
where he continues to serve in that
capacity please join me now in welcoming
Sasha thanks so much Mike and thanks
again to lab roots so today I will tell
you about plan of scale analysis with
millions of genomes and we're going to
start with a very small piece of one
genome my genome actually and if you
look at the little circle there's a see
there that is different in my genome
from most peoples that are watching
seminar this particular change is in the
AP AP 0 a 5 gene and it leads to
abnormal triglyceride levels I have them
my mother has them my grandmother had
them so it's a very real thing you know
in our family but interestingly enough
this um this change is not associated
with heart disease even though high
triglycerides normally our genomes are
complicated and understanding them is
going to take a huge amount of work this
is just one feature in my genome and
there are millions of features like this
so we're going to we're going to have to
look at slides like this for a very long
time probably several years if we want
to look at by genome and if we want to
look at millions of genomes then you
know you could do the math so so we need
we need to do something different from
that luckily you don't have to worry
about memorizing my genome or or
listening to me talk about it you can
just download it from this URL it's
actually publicly available
I have whole genomes from saliva from
blood and Exum all with different
platforms available at that URL as well
as phenotypes and many other things so
so you may wonder you know why would I
even make my genome public but but the
reason is that many many people are
going to have to share their data if
we're going to understand what genomes
mean and most people's data will be
private but it's incredibly helpful to
have some genomes that are publicly
available so that everyone can have a
starting point that is shared by by the
whole community so in the next five
years or so we're expecting about five
million whole genomes and many more
genotypes and exomes this is going to be
500,000 terabytes of raw data so you
know but an exabyte and that's an awful
lot of data how are we going to handle
all this well what I like to do is that
I like to build on the commons and and
this is something that has been
happening for decades now in the
internet scale businesses Linux powers
your Android phone the BSD demon powers
your iOS phone virtually all Internet
scale businesses use free software to
power their planet scale that data
centers and so a big part of the big
part of the Commons is free and open
source software and it's something that
that academics and life sciences are
only really getting used to using now so
so and pharmaceutical companies as well
are really just starting to get used to
the idea that the free software is
something that they should be using to
build their to build on for their work
the other important part of the common
is how my genome was able to be shared
with you so as Mike already mentioned we
are co-founders of the Personal Genome
Project George church's project at
Harvard Medical School and these are the
first ten participants in the Personal
Genome Project which when we started in
2005 was still an incredibly audacious
idea at the time we wanted to make this
data available to the participants
themselves and of course with it to the
general public not just to the research
elite there's an entrance exam to make
sure that people really know what
they're doing when they make their data
public and the hope was that we would
scale the project when we reached the
target of about a thousand dollars per
person for DNA and trade data and we've
actually reached that target this year
so there's a company called Veritas
there's now offering thousand-dollar
genomes to any consumer that wants to
get their whole genome sequenced and
this is something that's of course
available to BGP participants in
addition to making genomes and
phenotypes available we also wanted to
enable highly integrated holistic
systems biology so if you needed cells
from participants we hope to make them
available and today there are now
hundreds of cell lines available from
PGP participants that you can use in
your own functional studies and
experiments so building on the common
software and data public data we can ask
this question how do we organize
computational resources to serve the
needs of scientists physicians and the
general public and I think I've been
thinking about this question you know
for about a decade and one of the things
that is so so challenging is that when
you have exabytes of data you can't
necessarily make copies the of all of it
so if scientists wanted copies of the
exabytes and physician
want copies of the exabytes and the
general public have their own needs with
need that need copies of the exabytes it
really just gets way too expensive and
so we need to think about ways that we
we can create computational
infrastructure that they could answer
these different constituents needs at
the same time but where are we today
well if you work in a lab and you work
with genomes you've probably seen piles
of hard disk sitting on lab benches
these are old hard disks and so they're
a little bigger than the hard disks you
might get today but hard disks are hard
disks they're terrible to work with they
break they overheat it's nice that they
can be nailed to you but imagine that
you had to work with millions of these
hard disks in order to do your analysis
it's completely and utterly impractical
we need something better we need a
platform something that that that can
meet the needs of of all of the
different constituents that I mentioned
so we've all heard about Big Data we
know that internet scale companies have
been working with big data for a very
long time now but biomed does have
unique requirements there are sharing
requirements there are governance
requirements and their provenance the
reproducibility requirements and unique
data requirements that make biomed data
special that that will mean that our
platform has has features that may not
be available in other Internet scale big
data platforms so so the first of these
is sharing biomedical organizations
inherently need to share today when a
doctor sees a a case that they don't
know how to solve they'll call their
colleague sometimes on the other side of
the world and will say hey do you have a
patient kind of like mine
uh this has to happen at this scale
where now we're starting to generate
millions of genomes and you just can't
pick up the phone and ask a question
about a million patients so so sharing
is a challenge the the way we think
about sharing is to enable Federation
we'd like data to stay where it is in
the country or in foreign in control of
the organization that generated the data
and then we'd like questions to move to
the data so applications can move
through a federation and the question
can be answered in the control of the
organization the generator the data
Federation of course could be optional
or it could be used within an
organization if you're a multinational
company you have a sequencing and health
data all over the country or all over
the planet you simply can't move the
data out of the jurisdiction because of
local regulatory requirements so you
need Federation even even in a single
organization and of course data from the
Personal Genome Project and other public
data can be a resource that everyone
uses as well but there's another need
for sharing now Larry Page and Mark
Zuckerberg who both have amazing planet
scale computational infrastructure that
you know certainly the most
sophisticated in the world that planet
scale infrastructure doesn't need to be
used for sharing mark and Larry don't
have to share their customer data with
each other vayan that is different we
could spend this entire talk on
governance security and governance is
extremely important in health care how
health data is mostly private it's um
it's not going to be the case that that
people will generally make their genomes
available with notable exceptions
and so the the governance and security
requirements around this data are
enormous and so they really need special
attention jurisdiction by jurisdiction
organization by organization provenance
is also very important in biomed so this
is a Charles Darwin all life on Earth is
connected through evolutionary processes
and and and you can think of of those
those processes as as having a kind of
provenance you can see how things are
connected to their there are common
ancestors and and we need this and
biomed but again internet scale
companies don't need to worry about this
so when when Google and Facebook are
handling queries from their customers
people are searching for Paris Hilton
and they're searching for cancer and
they're searching for medicine and you
know these queries need to be answered
very quickly and if they can't
immediately answer the exact provenance
of why a particular search result was
presented to a particular person ten
years ago this really doesn't matter for
the Internet scale businesses but in
biomed if a life-or-death decision was
made for a patient based on a report
that was generated five years ago then
exactly how the report was generated is
important the provenance of that report
is important and so by med is different
in this way the data in biomed is also
unique you know genomic data is very
interesting because we understand it on
a atomic level we could write down a
genome almost atom by atom but we
certainly wouldn't want to do that that
description would be incredibly verbose
and in sometimes completely useless and
so we want compact descriptions that
that take advantage of the uniqueness of
biomedical data
when I think about weaving these
requirements together we get the air
vatos platform this is an open-source
platform for managing and analyzing
biomedical big data it's been running at
the Harvard Personal Genome Project
since 2007 this is kind of the simple
schematic architecture so if you start
at the top here you have applications
that run the personal genome projects
you have applications that support
precision medicine patient care
diagnostics pharmaceutical research and
all of these applications no matter
where they're running no matter where on
the planet they're running have common
features accessible to them data
management analysis provenance
governance sharing and then and then
underneath this you can run or vatos
anywheres it can be because it's open
source it can really be made to run
ubiquitously it can run on Amazon Web
Services and does today can run on
Google cloud platform on Microsoft azor
an OpenStack and all sorts of different
on-premise configurations so it can run
privately in your own data center it can
run in the public cloud and so the idea
is that we want a platform that will run
wherever the data is and that's why it
has to be open source so it can be
modified to meet the requirements of the
local configurations this is the
technical diagram the details are not
important of course a system like our
vadis was quite complex but the
important thing here is the URL if you
visit or vatos org you will find and the
github page you'll find all of the code
available you'll find all of the plans
of how the arado spa jecht is evolving
what's going to happen in the next two
weeks was going to happen over the next
few months there's active contributors
participating from all over the world
from Russia from the UK from various
parts of Asia and so obviously all over
the United States and Canada so so you
you can absolutely just go to this URL
and and start participating in the
community all of the software is free no
cost you can just download it now the
way that this the way that our vatos
gets used should be pretty familiar to
people who are used to any kind of sort
of data intensive science so in the
upper left here we have images this is
called primary analysis that's coming
off of the DNA sequencer these are
converted into a C's GS and T's these
called reads that's secondary analysis
then the secondary analysis leads to
Treasury analysis where you you have
questions about specific genetic
features like the one that I showed you
in my for my genome at the very
beginning so lightning is this component
of our relatives that lets you query all
patients with similar phenotypes
genotypes and out comes a planet scale
it needs to incorporate the spectrum of
human genetics nomenclature people have
been using genetic information to
diagnose patients and to treat patients
for decades and doctors have when they
called up their colleagues would use
these nomenclatures is e NH CBS Hugo and
so on to talk to each other about
feature genetic features in their in
their patients data we want to be able
to support all of these nomenclatures
and lightning and and so we're you know
we're working with a community to do
that for those people who are not
familiar with these kinds of diagrams
these are cytogenetic maps and they
they're sort of stylized pictures of
what DNA looks like when you skate when
you stay in
and look at it under a microscope people
who are only familiar with
next-generation sequencing think of Dean
of genome as being little a C's GS and
T's but obviously people who worked with
genomes several decades ago thought of
the more like this as karyotypes so how
do we support all of this nomenclature
are enlightening so we use a concept
called tiling which segments the genome
and provides a common inconsistent
coordinate system tiling begins by
choosing a tag set it's a group of
k-mers we make them 24 MERS there are at
least two bases from each other and
they're each found exactly once in the
pan genome of the species the tiling
that we use today has about 10 million
tanks so given given one of these
encoding 'he's we can convert a genome
into into tiles and i'll show you how
this works in a little bit more detail
but but if you remember the tile that I
or or the feature my genome that
originally showed you you can think of
that you can think of that as a tile and
if a change falls on one of the tags
when you skip ahead to another tag so
here's here's the here's the little bit
of my genome that I originally showed
you with the sea that leads to high
triglycerides my family now I've added
tags and then every organize the bases
in two separate tiles so there are seven
tiles in that original slide and the one
in the middle is the one with a see now
I'll just focus on that this is a single
tile the one that leads to high
triglycerides my family and the sequence
of letters and numbers that's underlined
at the bottom of my slide is a
consistent name is actually a
cryptographic hash that's generated from
the acs GS and T's in the tile and this
is a unique name for this particular
feature in my genome and so using this
technique you can build up a set of
unique tiles for the planets genomes and
ever every lab that uses the same tag
set will always get exactly the same
names for the same sequences this allows
us to at a very scalable way a wave is
scalable to millions of genomes
unambiguously talk about genetic
features with our colleagues without
having to worry that we have
misinterpreted what they were saying or
misapplied the sort of more doctor
friendly more human friendly
nomenclature and we can layer the human
friendly nomenclature on top of these on
top of these IDs um there are three
views in this slide the top view is a
sort of a standard genome browser the
one in the middle is actually a graph
that allows you to visualize a
population of tiles just for a very
small portion of a genome and then the
last part of this at the bottom of the
slide is a single tile this particular
tile is a extremely serious pathogenic
brca2 mutation and this was found in a
you know PGP participant and this person
reported having having breast cancer to
the project and there are many details
on tiling and so on at the preprint at
the bottom of the URL once you have
genomes encoded as tiles you can also do
machine learning so this is extremely
easily because because genomes become
arrays that you can work with very very
easily so here um you have a simple
principle components analysis the
x axis is a the first principal
component of the y-axis is the second
and if you take 680 whole genomes from
public data and you just plot them this
way they just separate quite naturally
and when you color code them it turns
out they cluster by ethnicities so you
can this is a very simple example but
you can also use the use this data to to
do many many other things so one of the
data scientists that works with me she
got really quite and for all with this
encoding when we discovered that from
just a handful of personal genome
project genomes she could identify the
specific part of the genome that was
responsible for blood type so that's a
very simple machine learning exercise
that in the past would take would take a
very very long time you know many sort
of phd's worth to actually isolate the
gene that was responsible for blood type
so once again um lightning lightning
queries are federated so the idea here
is that everywhere that you have our
vatos instances you also have lightning
instances and and you can ask questions
of each other's genomes you can say do
you have this tile in your genome or can
you give me all of the genomes that that
have this set of phenotypes or maybe
this combination of genotypes and every
organization that receives those
questions can decide for themselves or
they authorized to answer the question
or not the data never has to leave the
control of the organization that sets up
the
so that sets up the our vatos instance
and the Lightning instance so as I've
already said our mottos the Personal
Genome Project data all of these things
are open we have been developing open
standards along knit alongside these
software and data projects so we have
quite a lot of participation in the
Global Alliance for genomics and health
which is a standards organization that
is trying to emulate the w3c which is
developing standards for the Internet I
urge you to take a look at the GF for GH
also all of the the questions was I've
been talking about that arvada and
lightning allows you to ask and answer
these are described in a standard called
the common workflow language this is a
very popular sort of grassroots effort
by many organizations and
bioinformatician now several 100 by in
fermentations that is allowing by
informatics pipelines to be portably
shared across organizations so these
words have standards make it possible to
present personal genome project data to
present software like the vatos project
software in a way that can be used even
more broadly you know by people who want
to just a interface with these things
you know but not necessarily user vatos
themselves or not use a pgp data but by
using standards like from GA for GH or
the common workflow language these
things are these things are more broadly
accessible by taking advantage of these
standards
so I think that's that's it for my
presentation today i hope i hope to
answer your questions thank you so much
it's great so now we're going to move on
to the Q&A section and we I want to
remind you that a time if you have a
question and you'd like to ask please do
so now by just clicking in the green Q&A
button the bottom lower left over the
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click on the send button well answer
as many of your questions that we have
time for and so let's get started with
our first couple of questions as their
questions are coming and I have a
question for you Sasha first of all that
was great talk if somebody in our
audience wanted to look at your genome
and sort of explore it or any of the
genomes could they find for instance
that that April e5e peple a five-by-five
mutation could they find that by looking
at that what that URL that you gave yes
yes so you can actually download copies
of my raw data and you can also get
copies of genome reports to interpret
the data so you can do that for my
genome and for hundreds of other
people's genome so there's really a
growing interesting corpus of data that
is completely public and unencumbered
and so we've had actually a lot of
interest from from from high schools
that want to to work with this data and
they would never be able to work with
this data if if PGP project participants
were not willing to not willing to share
to sure you know and how much is it
exabyte so I exabytes a a million
terabytes and terabytes about one of
those hard drives okay so right so uh
one of our questions first
thanks for the great talk on planet
scale analysis I have a question about
where you think we are with a
standardization of tertiary analysis
such as alignment and variant calling
tools is there a set standard if not how
and when will we get there thank you so
I think that um I think that this is a
really important moment with projects
like the genome in a bottle initiative
that's run by the NIST to the National
Institute for Standards and technologies
to really standardized what a genome is
because I think it's really quite
surprising to the general public that
we've never actually completed every
single base in even a single genome and
so and so we have a lot ahead of us to
actually get to a place where we have
reference materials that you can just
order from NIST and and sequence
yourself and see you know does my
analysis lead to the correct answer so
NIST has shared about seventy percent of
the genome which they call confidently
called but it but until that other
thirty percent is finished you know
we're not going to have standardized
pipelines and so these these
standardized reference materials are
essential to make that happen okay
another question is where could I find
open source data for map genomes not
sure maybe that question is a little bit
we're done with mine where can I find
always or map he knows well the URL that
I mentioned at the beginning of the talk
does have everything from raw data raw
reads all the way to interpret it genome
so so you can
um you can see map genomes from the
Personal Genome Project okay next
question is happy to see the open source
platform for genomics research
unfortunately most databases and
software are getting commercialized what
is your comment on ethical perspective
and making all of them open source so uh
you know I work at a venture-backed
business and as well as being a
co-founder of the Personal Genome
Project and I think that what people are
not used to in life sciences that has
been long established in information
technology is that infrastructure can be
open source and then proprietary
innovation can occur on top of that on
top of that infrastructure and so there
is no reason why open technologies can
in a very sort of vibrant ecosystem
coexist with proprietary innovation and
that's actually separate from the fact
that the even if your software is open
source you can still have a very
successful commercial business around
that so most IT companies these days
that are making you storage systems or
making new other kinds of new machine
learning technologies these are based on
open source software which you can
actually download at no cost but these
are venture-backed businesses so in life
sciences life sciences this is still a
new concept okay let's see another
question is is there a software tool
repository my research group can make
contributions to it is that possible one
of the records to be part of this
initiative so everything is happening on
it completely in an open source
distributed way you can go to github
and participate there you can go to our
vatos org and participate there there
are no requirements on you at all and
the way that if you've never done
open-source development before it tends
to be a kind of ad hoc meritocracy where
where what you do is you take the code
on github you get it running it is it
doesn't do something you want it to do
you add a feature you talk about the
feature in the in the forums other
developers comment on your
implementation and then eventually you
do something called a pull request where
you say hey I've really gotten this
working can I contribute this code back
to the to the project and and sometimes
there's no additional conversations
before that pull request is incorporated
but that's that's kind of how the
open-source development works yeah I
think maybe the question the question
was from the point of view suppose you
have some sort of software the you nap
yeah it's something you've developed it
hole in right completely and you want to
add I to the arvada rat friend right
right so I'm sorry I think that um I
think that we are still working on how
that how that will work so we have
collaborations with GALEX the galaxy
project with the amp lab that creates
spar can much that the sort of
distributed computing infrastructure
that you power the Internet each of
these collaborations tends to be a
little bit different and so the best
thing to do is to just go either email
us or visit or bottle set org and just
just say hey we have some tools we'd
like to contribute and we'll find the
right place for them okay sounds good
I'm not sure I might understand this
next question clearly it says I would
like to know how we do a very verify the
genome in different methods from human
beings perhaps the question is about
other species or or is there any
challenges that verify the method
different mathema hema beings so maybe
other species have you is your platform
support that is lightning work with
other species for instance so for the
time being we are very focused on humans
but there's no reason that you couldn't
I'll non human genomes and and actually
we have a interest from contributors
that want to develop tilings of non
human genome so so one of the things
that open source projects can do is
connect people who are interested in
contributing with one another I wonder
you could use a ancestral data like Jim
poor other you know primate data
integrated with your tiling and find out
you know not only what the promoter
analysis but also ancestral yeah leal's
versus more yeah modern or legal yeah we
should we there's a project called the
monarch initiative that looks across all
life and so we hope to integrate it with
monarch over the next few years cool so
another question is are vatos mainly for
scientists bioinformaticians and IT at
institutions can an individual with
interest in environmental factors of
genomic research genomic research use
our vatos so um that they go back to but
to go back to this line back in this a
earlier picture I don't want secondly I
mentioned that vatos is a stack that
allows precision medicine applications
to kind of to run ubiquitously wherever
the data is generated the Personal
Genome Project has two applications are
in the top right corner here tapestry
and get a bit
that run the project and our hope is the
ordinary of people who are interested in
genomics will be able to use these
applications on chest PGP participants
but but any member of the general public
and you know the reality is that all all
projects like this are limited in
resources and so these these
applications are not very polish they're
still relatively technical they're not
focused on members of the general public
specifically but it is our hope to to
make this data accessible to the general
public and that's why we made this data
public you know we we want high school
students to be able to make sense of
this data and really um understand
genomics not just by hearing about it
through a press release yeah that's
great home okay another question I mean
I might have to paraphrase oh but how
much information expected per genome
once there are strong clusters and
relatively few mutations which are quite
similar let's see I guess that's the
main questions I guess once you once you
kind of know the population structure
and I guess a lot of the mutations of
population how much information is in a
human genome so I hope that answer this
question today so this is a great
question and I didn't get a chance to go
into it when i talked about tiling and
lightning but but but um our mentor
George George has been saying that the
genomes are really not a big deal there
are only four megabytes you can own you
can easily you know a picture off your
phone is bigger than four megabytes so
genomes are not big now for me you know
genome is hundreds of gigabytes of raw
data that comes off a sequencer so you
know how you get from 100
gigabytes of 4 megabytes see you know
seemed hard but the interesting thing
with our tiling encoding is that we now
have in the preprint we described an
encoding that's about forty megabytes
and uh we now have an experimental
version of lightning that can encode a
genome and four megabytes just as George
had said and so so it is going to be
possible to do real-time analysis on
millions of genomes because a single
genome can be represented very very
compactly now the library that the sort
of the library that that genome has to
refer to to make that work that library
will still be gigabytes it'll still be
quite large but it can be shared across
many many genomes right next question is
it feasible to use our vatos in clinical
diagnostic setups like cap CLIA
accredited labs so the nice thing about
open source infrastructure is that it is
used all the time and CLIA and cap
accredited labs and the way that works
is that if you decide to use our bodice
and people do use our bottoms in those
settings and they um they go through a
process of whether it's cap or whether
it's clear in which they demonstrate
that their process meets all of the CLIA
and cap guidelines and so nothing about
open source is an obstacle to that if
anything it you know could make it even
a little easier yeah yeah and while
waiting for another couple of questions
on my desk so you mentioned like galaxy
and other platforms that could you
compare I brought us to those platforms
for instance and how do you integrate ER
or not with those platforms today right
so we have a cooperation with the galaxy
project but which is really just getting
started it's around the
um common workflow language which I
mentioned so essentially when I talk
about moving questions to the data the
idea is that you express them using the
common workflow language and the galaxy
project is thinking about using common
workflow language as the way they
express their workflows and so will mean
that our vadis and galaxies can talk to
each other through cwl and so we hope
over the next year or two to have to
have this fully working in a way that
allows you to just move back and forth
you know and as a guy so galaxy this is
common work for language is something
that is is being industry it adopted at
this point yeah so common ruffle
language a the about eighty percent of
the spec was written by an engineer
occur verse okay uh and it has very
broad adoption seven bridges genomics is
a major leader of common workflow
language in Reverse as a leader the
galaxy project is a leader and there are
many many other organizations several
hundred by fermentations you know
they're participating in implementing in
implementing cewl yeah and so let me
just see if there's any other questions
here for you um I guess I'm still so it
is can you contrast the model you showed
is where you bring the computation to
the data is is galaxy traditionally like
a different model than that so a galaxy
has both um both models you there there
are sort of centralized galaxy instances
but the that you can use as a researcher
and you can send your data there and
that's kind of like a centralized galaxy
gear instance and then there are just
local galaxy instances that you can run
near your data right the big difference
between the model that we're trying to
implement with our bodice and and will
be possible for
galaxy as well is is to allow instances
to talk to each other yeah and to ask
questions of each other's data you know
so that that's where things get actually
very complicated right because of
security so the sense since your
security permission framework and my
security permission framework and all of
the rules around those permissions could
be quite different that means that you
need to do you need to have a lot more
software infrastructure and your latest
implement that that's not something
that's implemented the galaxy project
right yeah now I think and the last
question I asked you that the last
question they came in about the Clea and
the camps or the fight I think that
actually is perfectly addressed by that
because their data could be private as
you mentioned and that's right and
basically our vatos can bring it to them
whereas other platforms they might have
an option to play with right now they
don't have that option to do menus thats
Sarah that's great well I think we're
running at a time here and so there's no
more questions I think like to wrap up a
presentation so I'd like to thank you
again for their presentation and a being
final comments for our viewers oh I
think I think um one of the things that
is is a little bit hard to wrap your
head around with public data and open
source software and these open standards
is how do you know how do you fit in you
know you you have private data and you
have your own software that you're
developing and and and so you know I
urge you to look at what's been
happening in in internet scale
businesses where where there's this
collaboration between the open projects
and your own thing that you're doing in
your organization and so there's
absolutely a way for you to take
advantage of these resources
and you know the place to start is to
you know to go to arvada sorta org or to
go to github or to go to the URL that I
showed for downloading this data and
take advantage of it it's there you know
for you great great alright well thank
you once again Sasha and I'd like to
thank our sponsor lab roots for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I want to let everyone know
that today's webcast will be available
on-demand viewing random and viewing
after today's live event on the lab
roots website you will receive an email
from labrada you know when it's
available for replay please share that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event and
so that's all for now thank you for
joining us and goodbye